to staggering new projections for how
many Americans could die from the
coronaviruses states start to reopen
warm spring weather and East
restrictions in a lot of states have led
more Americans to gather in public
spaces like the parks and the shopping
malls
now one model once frequently cited by
the White House is warning about the
risks of rushing the recovery less than
a week ago a group at the University of
Washington projected America's death
toll would hit 72,000 by August 4th
now they warned that number could
sharply rise to one hundred and thirty
four thousand if strict measures like
social distancing are eased we'll have
more on the second model shortly but
first Janet shamlian is in Houston which
is partially open again despite a spike
in cases in Texas from the public health
point of view namely there will be more
deaths Chris Murray director of the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation at the University of
Washington isn't mincing words relaxing
social distancing guidelines too soon he
says will cause a major spike this rise
in the last week or 10 days is likely
leading to some increased transmission
the models projections which have been
favored by the White House worried
health officials as states across the
country reopen Katie Meeks owns a
Houston toy store once again open people
called the day before asking and they
were here at first thing ready to shop
in person with their masks on are you
having any issues with social distancing
no I would say for the most part people
have been respectful we've put a sign on
the door asking people to please wear a
mask when they come in and reminding
them that we will be practicing social
distancing in the store people wore
masks in her store but across the
country more instances of defiance in
Flint Michigan three people are charged
with murder for allegedly killing
security guard Calvin motherland' at
this Family Dollar Store on Friday
surveillance video authorities say
appears to show the 43 year old father
of eight was shot and killed for telling
a customer to wear a mask
I parents grew up together our kids grow
up together meanwhile in Boston protests
continued with hundreds gathering in
close proximity outside the Statehouse
demanding the economy reopen some
holding signs reading everyone is
essential and in California amid growing
pressure governor Gavin Newsom announced
some low risk businesses like bookstores
and florists can open for curbside
pickup on Friday and following days of
protests beaches in to Orange County
cities will also open with restrictions
this is a very positive sign and it's
happened only for one reason the data
says it can happen and for California
that same study out of the University of
Washington shows an expected doubling of
cases and deaths by the end of August in
New York Governor Cuomo is looking at
taking a similar tact as that of
California but only after lockdown ends
on May 15th and only after certain
tracing and testing requirements have
been met Tony all right Janet thank you